hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers my
name is Taylor chamber and this is
Tara's the Racine and today we're
tackling something that we completely
missed from childhood and that is the
Simpsons today we are watching season 1
of The Simpsons which we completely
missed growing up yeah we stayed strong
with that one still haven't seen any of
it finished altar critic people they're
like used to me not having a scene
things but I said I hadn't seen the
Simpsons and they were like that is
surprising I don't know you were born
yet but like what I was really young mom
didn't even want me watching the Rugrats
so that was a thing miles around okay so
Simpsons was definitely an hour and then
you miss so much of something that you
feel like ah it's not going to the point
oh wait you snap with me right hand one
two
[Music]
[Applause]
but you can tell it's going to be a show
filled with comedy but in this first
season it's better at telling stories
than it is about telling jokes we
thought it was gonna be like 26 episodes
it was only 13 episodes thank you that
was amazing that was a really wonderful
surprise we were on episode 11 we were
like gathers so much we're not even
halfway and then we looked for the first
time you know one more but I've been
told that the simpsons is like it's
revolutionary they have new ideas
especially in the earlier seasons
they're like no it's all pop-culture
references and blah blah but in the
earlier seasons it was like new ideas
innovative incredible and I feel like
they're not talking about season two
season three and four okay so why it's
rough tell me later
sure there's there's like one person
animating this whole thing really I I
think so it's the person like well and
if there was more not many more and like
the budget obviously wasn't huge because
it's a brand-new show and so like it's
animations kind of and like the voice
acting they didn't know their characters
yet so that's kind of like it didn't
spend the full nine months in its mother
it's more wholesome than anything really
at this point honestly it's got a lot of
heart like a lot of the episodes I was
like these are some topics that are
relevant still today and then some of
them most of them were these are topics
that I've seen a million times and not
done
well as others that I have seen so like
the only show that I can compare this to
like readily is family items and
whenever they address the subject they
still come out it's still way based in
like cartoon lens oh it's silly it'll be
fine but in like Simpsons it's still
it's still gonna be fine but like they
still kind of poke at like this is kinda
real so it's gonna be a little I
cut the bottom like okay cuz like you
said like whatever they bring up money
it's like I'm having to aspect of them
being lower middle class you have the
aspect of him having this job it's not
secure in this aspect of like you know
three kids in a family and like a dog
very normal family and it just so it
feels real she writes notes when we
watch these things I don't do that she's
a professional
obviously like she said like there
wasn't many knows I was like nothing
really stands out first thing that we
recognized and heard was the intro
sounds like the Jetsons intro I was
gonna the dresses intro to the trope are
the same if the Simpsons opening ripped
off from the Jetsons
but we were right let's talk about the
first episode which is one of the ones
that left the biggest impact on me I'm
always going to be impacted by a show
that talks about money issues around
Christmas might one of my favorite
episodes of Hey Arnold is the Christmas
episode where in the boarding house they
all buy each other one gift for one
person you get one gift from a random
human in the boarding house cuz money's
tight and that always impacted me this
one the same they have to spend all
their Christmas savings on a tattoo
removal on part that kind of deviates
from the like Christmas special story
that we we'd come home
been trying to raise money for the
family Christmas and he can't he's been
unsuccessful he made $13 and then he'd
bend it all the way it turns out the dog
he bet on runs away and he gets to keep
the dog him and Bart take the dog home
and he comes in to tell the family that
he tried his very hardest and that you
tried to make Christmas nice for this
family but he was unable to and then
before you can see what the family
thinks Bart is just like we got a dog
I'm like good little scrawny mud runs in
and everyone's like really happy and
it's so sweet and it was honestly like a
really good way to start out the series
and then for a couple of episodes after
that it was just like okay these are all
things I've seen before this isn't the
smartest character in all Lisa I love
Lisa so damn hard I like the part where
she's like she's like that I'm sad and
he was like well tell me all about it
it's like she's like you won't
understand and he's like oh sure I well
she's like well I just don't get what
how we can relax when there's so much
suffering
it's like let's drop that bomb in the
middle of the living room if you like if
this continues to get better like it has
over that season it got better if this
continues to get better I could see
myself super getting into the show by
catching up which would be an
undertaking let me tell you but doing
that with one piece there's like there's
like nine hundred episodes right now I'm
on like 300 something right now that's
absolutely insane I will never watch it
going around it gets really good around
like 280 absolutely not I wrote episode
10 so really good women's women's rights
lisa has some depression and she uses
her saxophone to write a song about it
and and it's honestly it's so so good
and i sat there just like damn 1990 is
one
came out like this is like tackling some
things that are still being tackled
that's cool I really enjoyed that I
think that's cool it seems very I had a
bit time in some aspects and then like
we decided so many other aspects super
not I liked it and I liked the
directions going way more than I liked
it in the beginning of Tamra's never
seen it when I really tackled giant
movies like like Jurassic Park and and
back to the future like things that like
how did you miss those camera those
movies it was really exciting to see all
the references within it it's similar
with this I feel a lot of excitement
like welling up in me to see this which
is just such a huge thing culturally I
still haven't seen Jurassic Park in like
20 minutes we got at 66 you'll hate the
animation but laugh and be endeared it
to the sweeter moments yeah yeah agreed
you will be able to quite clearly see
the building blocks of what the show
would go on to become it already had it
satirical edge emotionally driven
storylines and great sense of humor but
it was yet to be perfected that's giving
it a lot of credit I don't think it had
its satirical edge quite yet and I don't
I really don't think it had a great
sense of humor in this first one but it
was able to tell a story really well it
really wants to be funny but it's not
quite there yet you'll find it loud when
they eat but episodes that focused on
Marg and Lisa to be lovely I did not
notice the loud eating did you
it looks much worse but it's so much
funnier proof that substance is better
than polish I disagree hard these are
not gonna be the Simpsons you now know
so no now I don't know I don't know we
don't but I am excited to see how it
works and changes in a box is it all the
senses you know you if we all don't love
right guys right right everyone do it oh
that is because like but like only like
a list of five that show up enough to
make it fun because there's like one
online and there's like 30 rules yeah
it's like I can't keep track five good
one I kind of watched this you know who
leave them in the comments yeah let us
know your favorite Simpsons drinking
games thank you so much for watching I
will see you next week with a movie but
then the week after that we're gonna
continue on with since the Simpsons
season 2 for something that's it I'm
gonna watch the Brokeback Mountain no
wait what's the thing and Jake
Gyllenhaal no Gyllenhaal yeah you
fletcher's the other one have you not
seen it oh all right well we'll see well
next where's your donut go
[Music]
[Applause]
you